alright thanks everyone so yeah I'm
going to talk about robustness and
separation and multi-dimensional
screening if you're not familiar with
this terminology so i'll say
multidimensional or you can mentally
replace it with multidimensional
mechanism design it's exactly the same
thing so the the place that I'd like to
start from is the observation that
multi-dimensional mechanism design is
hard right I think this is on something
that's familiar to all of us so with one
dimension that you're a monopolist and
you're you're selling a single good to a
buyer with a quasilinear utility you
know we have a very nice solution to the
optimal mechanism problem right so I'm
you're trying to sell I don't know
wireless clickers you could come up with
all kinds of complicated interactions
with the buyer involving multiple rounds
and randomization but the best thing to
do is simply post a single price whereas
when there is more than one good sort of
all hell breaks loose and we we know
that even when there was just two goods
even when the buyers values for the two
goods are independently distributed and
even when there is no complementarity so
the value forgetting nor the wireless
clicker and the sunglasses is the same
as the value for the clicker plus the
value for the sunglasses right so
Christo's just now at the beginning of
his track mentioned a few of the few of
the examples of bizarre behavior that
can occur maybe bizarre or maybe maybe
just maybe exciting depending on your
perspective so we saw very often the
optimal mechanism involves bundling and
not just showing the two goods together
but selling each good with some
probability that strictly between 0 and
1 at some price you might in fact want
to offer infinitely many probabilistic
bundles at different prices and let the
buyer choose among them and we have
other other examples of ways in which
this problem is maybe babe surprisingly
so for example the optimal revenue can
be non monotone in the value
distribution right it can happen that
the buyers values for all goods
go up and yet your maximal revenue
actually goes down so these things for
an economist interested in
multi-dimensional screening the finger
frustrating because it's an important
problem we'd like to be able to have
simple simple models to work with right
so basically any kind of screening
problem you could think of it so
naturally formulated in a way where
there might reasonably be multiple
parameters affecting someone's
preferences so monopoly sales is a
canonical example that we often look
about look at but you can think about
you know regulation of monopoly say burn
arson or you can think about a taxation
problem where say people can produce
different amounts of income but the
different positive effort by choosing
different jobs maybe a person has
several jobs so you can think about
dynamic taxation over multiple periods
you can think about the problem of
designing an insurance policy where
somebody might you know privately know
how vulnerable they are two different
kinds of losses or how vulnerable they
are two different kinds of diseases say
and you know there's lots of diseases
out there so you probably have multiple
dimensions of private information so in
order to be able to be able to think
about these kinds of applications we'd
really like to have a tractable way of
modeling multi-dimensional screening
problems so what I'm going to talk about
is a general but bland model and result
so I'm going to describe a model where
there are no interactions between the
the different say the different goods
that are being sold either in terms of
information that you the seller have
about them or in terms of the buyers
preferences and the result unlike most
of the sort of classic bundling models
is that you also want to sell the goods
separately
so and I think maybe in terms of
multi-dimensional mechanism design
models this is sort of the most boring
one that you could ask for but my hope
is that this can be this can be a base
on which on which future work can build
so here is the idea of the model you're
a seller sewing circle goods and you
don't actually have a have a prior joint
distribution over the buyers value for
say the wireless clicker and the
sunglasses you only know the
distribution of values of for the
clicker and the distribution of values
for the sunglasses separately but you
don't know how these are correlated with
each other and you want you want a
mechanism that is robust to this
uncertainty so you evaluate any
mechanism in terms of its worst case
guarantee on your expected revenue and
so the result is that it's optimal to
solid good separately so in this case
you would post a price for the clicker
and the buyer can buy or not about price
and you separately post the optimal
price for the sunglasses this result is
hopefully not not surprising when stated
it's fairly intuitive and because you're
solving a maximun problem might if you
look if you're like--you're your
adversary is nature choosing the Joint
Distribution over values for the goods
and we know the solutions to max mean
problems tend to be things that equalize
your payoff against lots of things that
your adversary can do and in this case
by selling the goods separately you
equalize your payoff across all possible
joint distributions because well you're
your profit from selling the wireless
clicker depends only on the marginal
distribution of values for the clicker
and your profit from the sunglasses
depends only on that marginal is a
single distribution which leads to this
is the separate selling is optimal yeah
I will get there so um so I would like
to have a proof of the statement that
builds directly on this observation that
that equalizes your payoff against all
of the all the distributions it I have
not found a proof that builds directly
on this so so the actual proof that I'll
outline towards the end of the talk in
the last uh for four or five minutes is
a bit more
complicated but first I'll try to argue
for why there is not a more obvious
proof but basically the lesson of this
result is if you don't know enough to
see how to bundle the goods then you
shouldn't bundle them I stated the
results so far in terms of a monopolist
selling several goods but actually the
result is much more general so really it
says that if you have if you have an
agent who has K dimensions of private
information or i should say pieces of
private information because i don't want
to even think of each piece is
necessarily one-dimensional k pieces of
private information and for each piece
are supposed to choose a corresponding
allocation and the agent preferences are
additively separable across the K
allocation problems and he's
quasi-linear so preferences are just
some minus of minus a payment we
generally if you know the marginal
distribution of each of each type each
data but you don't know how they're
correlated and you're you have a
worst-case objective with respect to
this then the optimal thing to do is
solve each of the K problem separately
this good professional gamer oh yeah is
it uniquely optimal to sell them
separately or there are some mechanisms
that do just as well in the worst case
but sometimes it'd be better uh so for
the cases that I have looked into which
is where we're there you're selling a
bunch of goods and there the finite type
distribution for each good then so
generically it's uniquely optimal up to
look up to the possible cases where
there might be several prices you're
indifferent over I don't know about the
full a general problem
ok here is the related literature slide
that that everybody hates this is
related to several strands of work
particularly work on multi-dimensional
screening which many people in this room
have contributed to so there are several
lines of working of those though we're
showing the simple mechanisms are
optimal and or are approximately optimal
and I think of this being particularly
in that vein so I've already sketched
out the model I'll describe it in in
full detail to make sure that hopefully
you know I'm acuity so so so the the
constituent parts of our problem are
these in called screening problems so
this is a sort of classic textbook
mechanism design problem it consists of
four parts or the space of types that
your agent might have there's a space of
allocations you can choose agent has a
pair for each type for each allocation
that depends on his type and you have a
prior over types and a mechanism which
assumes her out can be probabilistic
specifies for each possible type a
distribution over allocations and a
transfer and it has to satisfy the usual
I see nir constraints so in such a
screening problem you have a prior over
types your objective is to maximize the
expected payment of the agent so what
I'm interested here is a is a joint
problem that is composed of several
several of these component problems
right sterling or selling several goods
each good gives you a component problem
selling them together is a joint problem
so the in the joint screening
environment the agents type is type
spaces the product of the component type
spaces type specify the value for each
good say and allocation space similarly
the product of the separate allocation
spaces and the payoff function is just
assumed to have this without a dip least
approval form the only thing is that you
don't have you don't have a prior over
types in this environment the joint
screening mechanism specifies specifies
a probabilistic allocation and a payment
for each type and there are appropriate
version of the ICN I are constraints is
dis should satisfy
and allocation and the payment can
depend on the entire type right so there
is no presumption that you know that the
x1 allocation depends only on on type
theta1 and so forth so in yr the Delta Y
is it Delta's piece by piece alright so
because of the additively separable
preferences right so in principle you
could you your mechanism could be
distribution over the whole allocation
of this big X but it's enough to
consider randomizing over each component
independently because of the supper
ability okay so when you have any
mechanism you evaluated by the the worst
possible expected profit overall Joint
Distribution on a typeface that have the
given marginals so one thing you can do
is for each component you can apply the
optimal mechanism for that component by
itself and the agents payment will just
be the sum of the payments in each of
those mechanisms and I'll write our star
one for the optimal mechanism revenue in
component one our store two and so forth
and just our star for the sum of those
so the separate screening mechanism
gives you profit of our star no matter
what the Joint Distribution is and the
result is that you can't guarantee more
than that so talk about applications up
so selling several goods for example
clickers in sunglasses your your theta K
your type for good k is just your value
for the good and the allocations are
either you get the good or you don't get
it but I'm allowing probabilistic
mechanisms and so mechanism in principle
can specify probability of getting each
go to the function of your whole type
and we know that the the single good
optimal mechanism is just a posted price
and so this theorem says in this in this
setting this robust setting the optimal
way of selling all the goods is just
post a price for each one
you want to make this a little more
complex you can think about nonlinear
monopoly problems or something like I'm
a service and quality choice or or our
quantity choice goes allocating
continuous quantities where the age and
preference over quantity says
parameterised by by his type theta K and
so in general then within each component
problem very good the optimal mechanism
would not be a single posted price
instead of to be a menu of quantities of
the agent could get at different prices
usually when we write down these these
models we make some assumptions to
simplify the problem so we'll assume the
space of possible preference types is
one-dimensional and there's some kind of
a single crossing or so for my Julie
already conditioned in the preference in
the payoff function we don't actually
need any of these assumptions for the
theorem to apply so these assumptions
help us explicitly solved for the
optimal mechanism but even without
knowing these even without these
assumptions it's still true that the
robust optimal mechanism for selling
several goods is just to use the optimal
menu for each good separately and I
don't want to say this is a theorem only
about monopolist selling multiple goods
so there are other applications for
example there the discussion in the
paper about application to a merely
style optimal taxation problem where you
can interpret the the multiple component
problems either as an agent's income
from from different jobs that you could
do or or income in several different
time periods but I won't talk about that
here for four reasons of time so before
I talk about the the proof of the
theorem I should describe some ways you
might try to prove this it don't work so
the the proof is going to be exactly
like oh I know on suggested there will
actually be a particular worst-case
distribution such that you can't get
more than our star from any mechanism
and so the strategy is going to be to
find our distribution so the first thing
you might try is just have the different
components of type be independent of
each other right so if you're if you're
you're selling severals and separate
goods there's no interaction in
conferences across the goods and there's
no
informational interaction because the
these values are independently
distributed then then you would want to
solve a good separately right as we know
this this doesn't work so christus just
now showed us an example where you have
two goods and doggies one or two for
both another way to see this fails is if
you have a large number of goods and the
values are IID then by the law of large
numbers you know almost certainly what
the value for the grand bundle is and so
you can extract almost all the surplus
by selling the bundle in fact the
independent distribution basically never
works so McAfee mcmillan Winston had a
paper where they made this observation
very cleanly if you were to start by
selling each good at the optimal posted
price and then you offer an epsilon
discount for just a bundle of all goods
you can see by the first order condition
that small epsilon discount actually
improves your profit ok so the
independent distribution doesn't work
here's another thing that you might try
so so for inspiration actually let think
about the special case where there are
where the you're selling k goods and the
marginal distribution of values for each
good are all the same so you know that
the distribution of values for the
clicker and for the sunglasses are
identical well one natural joint
distribution you could imagine is one
where where the consumer is just
distributed along the diagonal in this
value space and so is value for the
clicker and the sunglasses are equal
that reduces this whole joint problem to
a one-dimensional problem and it's clear
that the optimal thing to do is to sell
the whole bundle at at K times the
single posted price but that's the same
as in this case as just selling each
good separately at the posted price so
you might try to generalize this now and
say well what about what about if the
marginal distributions are not all
identical so one one way to try to
generalize this is by having the values
for the different Goods be as positively
correlated as possible so the imagine
that the
the value for the goods are jointly
distributed along some upward sloping
curve in the value space that happens to
give you the correct marginal on good
one and on good too so there is a couple
of problems with this I mean one is that
when they try to get to the general
theorem where you're not just not just
selling goods but each of your component
problems is some some abstract mechanism
design problem it's not really clear how
to do this because then each for each
component problem the types are not
necessarily ordered but even in the
particular application of a monopolist
selling k goods this doesn't always work
yeah it it sometimes works but let me
show you a counter example so here is
the counter example so there's two goods
good 1 and good 24 good one the buyer
could have value either one or two with
our ability a half each and for good to
the probability values could be two
three or four with probabilities
one-third 16 Thor one-half these are
equal revenue distributions so for a
good one you can price either at one or
two and either way your profit will be
14 good to you could price either at two
three or four and either way or your
profit will be too and so in this case
if you sell the goods separately or your
your total revenue is three
so if you take this this c'mon
electronic distribution the distribution
for which the values are is positively
correlated as possible this is what it
looks like so there's a math point on
values 1 comma 2 of size 13 13 of size
16 and one end to four sides one half
and I claim that this distribution
doesn't hold you down to revenue of
three so I claim you can do strictly
better than three with this distribution
and here's a way to do it in fact here
is the optimal mechanism for this case
you allow the buyer to buy either good
one at a price of one or good to at a
price of three or both goods but to buy
both goods you have to pay an extra
premium not to pay five if you do this
then it's incentive compatible for the
low type of buyer to buy just good one
the middle type to buy just good to in
the high type to buy both goods and you
calculate your revenue in this case and
it is 10 / 3 which is more than the
three you get from selling them
separately so what's going on here in
this example can we relate this to our
usual intuition about one dimensional
mechanism design and see what goes wrong
well one thing to notice here is that
this mechanism is not monotone for each
good separately right so the low type of
buyer and the high type of buyer are
both getting good one but the middle
type isn't and so basically there is a
there is a kind of aggregate
monotonicity constraint that holds in
the multi-dimensional setting but it's
not as strong as requiring monotonicity
for each good separately and so that
relaxation of monotonicity allows us to
charge an extra premium for the
incremental good to that the high type
of getting there by making a profit of
more than two dollars on that good
so I claim that there is that there is
some particular distribution that does
in fact guarantee you can't get more
than three revenue so here is the here
the distribution in this example it's
not the only one but it's the one that
is calculated by the algorithm that all
quickly sketch and I don't understand
what this distribution is so if these
numbers are meaningful to you I would
love to hear from you all right so now
I'll quickly sketch how the how the
actual proof works so I'll prove just
the the finite version of the theorem
where the type spaces are finite and the
allocation spaces are finite and there
this extends to the continuous case just
by a straightforward approximation
argument so basically the proof is by LP
duality so right each of the component
screening problems as a linear program
and if we know that in screening problem
number 5 you can't get more revenue than
RS are five then there exists dual
variables that certify that there exists
multipliers on each of the constraints
such that when you multiply the
constraints and then you add them up you
get an inequality that says tada any
mechanism won't give you revenue more
than our star five so i would like to
simultaneously well i would like to
construct multipliers for the joint
screening program that prove the same
thing but i don't know what the joint
distribution is so i'm going to have to
show this for some particular
distribution that we construct and so
the trick is will construct the
distribution and the multipliers for the
joint problem at the same time and at
the end we have to check that everything
is non-negative both the multiplier than
the probabilities and checks as the
Joint Distribution we constructed really
is a joint distribution with the
marginals it's supposed to have
yeah there are quite a lot of
constraints in the joint screening
problem because you have this big
multi-dimensional space of types and in
principle any type could could
misrepresent as being any other type so
actually look at a relaxed problem where
we only use a subset of the constraints
in which constraints i'll use i'll use
just the ones where type considers
misrepresenting one component of the
type and all the other components are
reported truthfully and moreover all use
only the constraints that correspond to
constraints that were binding in the
individual component problems so for
example if this horizontal axis
represents component problem number one
so these are these five dots are types
in a component problem these blue arrows
represent incentive constraints that are
binding at the optimal solution here and
the red arrows represent participation
constraints that are binding at the
optimal solution and similarly for
problem two here on the vertical axis
here is my space of joint types in the
joint screening problem i'm going to use
just these incentive and participation
constraints so the incentive constraints
are the horizontal arrows that
correspond to these and the vertical
arrows that correspond to these and for
the participation constraints i'll use
only the ones for the types where the
participation constraint binds in every
component simultaneously and a big sense
that i would look only at these
constraints because if in fact that we
are going to show is that the separate
screening is optimal well these are the
constraints that are binding for
separate screening so they should be the
only ones that matter
okay so I can I can do this in a little
bit more detail right so what exactly is
a mechanism for a component problem well
also it specifies for each possible type
in this component a probabilistic
allocation that is a probability of
every possible outcome and a transfer
and these after satisfy a bunch of
linear constraints as usual so there is
an icy constraint for each type to
imitate any other type there was an IR
constraint and there is a non negativity
constraint that says all these
probabilities are non-negative and then
there is an adding-up constraint that
says the probabilities of each of the
outcomes have to add up to one for every
possible type and by duality we know
that there is some numbers you can
multiply these things by by these
numbers and add them up and you'll get
all of the x's will cancel and the t's
will will end up with coefficients equal
to the probabilities and you'll get this
magical inequality
so what I'd like to do is find
corresponding multipliers for the joint
screening problem so I'd like to find
the joint screening problem just like
the component problem x IC constraints I
are constraints non negativity and
adding up constraints I'd like to find
multipliers so that when we multiply
each of these by the right coefficient
add them up we get this inequality that
total profit is at most our star that is
the sum of the revenues from the
component problems I put the
probabilities here though in a different
color because the probabilities are not
something that that currently is
specified so it's up to us to find the
probabilities such that such that the
algebra works out so this is a proof
strategy and actually once i have
described this proof strategy is
basically straight forward to work
through it once you decide to do this
the algebra will lead you to what the
multipliers have to be um but there are
a bunch of things to check so it turns
out that once you start trying to
calculate the multiplier that makes this
thing work they're basically related
versions of the multipliers from the
corresponding opponent problems so for
each type in the joint tight space and
each of the k directions usually the K
component that was going you're going to
have to come up with some rewriting
coefficient which I called gamma K of
theta so that the joint multiplier is on
on constraints involving that type in
this direction are simply the readings
of the corresponding component
constraints so the gamma looks at all
the the other items and the
corresponding I'll only get one item so
I ask the question again so what is
dying two different items into the army
that's right yeah
in another way of saying it is so the if
I look at for example the incentive of
this type to imitate this type this type
is getting an allocation to consist of
all items in this type of getting an
allocation of the consists of that
considers that a consists of all items
and in the one-dimensional problem this
type has a different valuation for the
first item then this type does in the
joint problem this type has a different
valuation for the first a different
value for the first item but the same
value for the second item and so that's
going to make the that's going to make
the joint constraints a bit more complex
than the component constraints and so
that's where we need the the gammas to
come in so basically we want to pick out
these gammas in a way that makes it so
that when we add up all of our
constraints all the code all of the x's
cancel out and we are left with just the
t's well there are this number of gammas
that we need to choose one for each for
each joint type and each each direction
and there's also this many constraints
on what the gammas are because we need
each of the XS to cancel out and so this
is a this looks like it should be a
uniquely determined system and it turns
out that it not only has a solution but
the solution ends up being non negative
I don't understand why the solution to
the system ends up being non negative so
I can show it by a by a fixed point
argument the fact that it's not negative
is it is important for the for the proof
approach to work because that means all
the multipliers are our inequality
constraints which need to be
non-negative actually are and then
finally once this determines what the
multipliers on the constraints are well
we also needed to to decide what the
probabilities on on the joint types but
those are pinned down because because we
just multiply each of these constraints
by the appropriate multiplier we add
them up and we look at the we look at
the resulting coefficient on T of theta
and we call that thing probability pi of
theta
and it turns out that those piyo Thetas
are closely related to the to the
component the probabilities in the
corresponding component problems in fact
they are exactly equal to the marginal
probabilities ree weighted by these
gammas oh yeah so for each xk basically
i want to choose these are awaiting
coefficients so that when i do this big
adding up xk of theta will cancel out
here so that gives me one constraint for
each xk of theta some of a cave that
elastic living room no so this is true
for every k yeah and you can do that
once you sort of identify once you use
these constraints to pin down what gamma
the gammas have to be this gives you a
relationship between the component the
component problems and the joint
problems with gamma figuring in there
somehow and it turns out that this comes
out of these are in a sense of light
enough for assessing started with a
uniform distribution over twice and you
have anything no I i I'd drawn a bunch
of pictures of what the what the these
worst-case distributions look like and
haven't been able to make sense of them
if anyone can look at the pictures and
interpret them I would love to know yes
should be again offering for the exact
mini-moon that's going to be tough but
for the direction of the beam go from
negative correlation which means when
one low values and and that's exactly
yeah rather than rather than food
coloring positive correlation which is
what you showed us it seems to me so for
example good a separate be as high as
possible for separate I'm saying in you
goes from the negative correlation
that's my dude I don't know that's your
does your picture look though
like it's going that direction so the
picture the generated by taking like
uniform distribution so I don't have
them in this in this talk unfortunately
but they tend to look like there's
positive correlation the usual lesson
coming from the bundling literature has
been that we want to bundle and there is
negative correlation right but here
London see visually we're finding is bad
right and that's rather than separate
exactly when when when someone is Heidi
either is low so you are going to lose
that when you bundle it you want to
separate it Katie two on the right path
I don't know that that could be my maybe
we should take a take this offline
sensors I think one minute remaining or
possibly less okay yeah so well so here
is a quick summary and and in the future
I'd like to build on this by using this
is a baseline boring model to
incorporate interactions between the
different components of information and
see whether we can build more general
and more tractable multi-dimensional
screening models house